well we begin this newshour with
breaking news out of iraq where protests
are taking place against october's
parliamentary election results now there
are clashes as you can see from these
live pictures between protesters
and security forces we understand that
stones have been thrown
and tear gas has been deployed this of
course follows those parliamentary
elections in october
let's see if we can get more now from
mahmoud abdul wahidz he joins us now
live from baghdad uh mahmoud these are
dramatic pictures we're showing our
viewers
just give us a sense of the concept why
are these protests happening
and
and why have they seemingly spiraled out
of control
well hell apparently a violence
escalated after the protesters are
starting
started they started
throwing security forces with the stones
and then security forces near the green
zone area
also tried to fire in the air to
disperse the protesters and also they
fired a tear gas now these protesters
are supporters of the political parties
that lost in the legislative election
that was conducted the last month
they include
popular mobilization forces these are
the military arm of the political
parties that lost in the election
remember
the escalation or the violence has
escalated after the protesters announced
it that today friday is the last chance
for the government for the election
commission to
re to hold a recount of all the votes
otherwise to conduct
re-election now these protesters have
been occupying areas near the green zone
for the third month
now they have been setting tents they
have been uh marching in the area they
have been chanting uh against the
government against the election
commission against international uh
commissions including the the un mission
and the european union mission that have
uh taken part in monitoring the election
in fact they accuse
the election commission of votrigging of
fraud
and they also uh they have went they
have gone far to demand uh the removal
of all the staff of the election uh
commission now uh these protesters uh uh
as you know they they include they
include uh popular mobilization forces
we spoke to many of them they said that
they were uh commanded they were
commanded to leave their military
positions in many areas across iraq and
the south and the north and the west of
the country and come here near the green
zone uh to protest to
build to set up their their tents and
not leave the area until the demands are
met now the situation is getting uh
worse because
the election commission says that it's
impossible to
be to conduct a re-election
given the fact that it has conducted
already about 25 percent
of the votes
have been recounted manually and
eventually the results are identical
with the old results so there is no
change
there is no hope for these protesters to
leave the area because they are not
happy with the
work they are not happy with the results
they are not happy with uh the recount
of the uh this beauty votes because they
say that the disputed votes have been
recounted only with a supervision from
the election commission in fact they say
that they are not leaving this this area
near the ground the green zone until uh
a recount is connected to all the votes
would a recount be
i mean i mean it's would a recount be
enough to to to get these protesters to
stand back just as we were talking mark
moods uh it certainly looks like
protesters are now charging one uh
appears to be carrying a chair
charging at a line of riot police there
it's this there seems to be a lot of
tensions on the street where our cameras
are appointed
what would it take for these protesters
to to back down has there been any
evidence of wrongdoing when it came to
the election or the counting progress
itself or are they just unhappy
because they've lost
well they have been calling for uh
uh protesters to take to the streets uh
today on friday they call it like i said
uh the last a chance the last chance
means that this is the last uh chance
for peaceful protesting for peaceful
demonstration and then
they would escalate and that is exactly
what happened they
started throwing stones at the security
forces security forces replied with tear
gas and firing shooting in the air
we have been getting reports from the
protesting area that
there have been injuries there have been
injuries among
the protesters and they say
that they have been also calling
protesters in other governments in other
provinces to take to uh the streets and
but on the at the same time the election
commission said that it's preceding uh
it's a proceeding with its work it will
refer the results of the
disputed uh votes to the federal court
to pass
the final judgment we have been speaking
to uh
commissioners with the election
commission they say that there is no
change there is no change
there is no uh difference there is no
comparison there is no difference uh the
the the new results with the the old
results that's why they say that they're
going to
refer the all the results
especially the disputed the results of
the disputed votes to the federal court
to pass the final judgement but one
commissioner says that
the federal courts will most probably
endorse the results because there is no
clear evidence
about the vote trigging there is no uh
legal standing for those uh who are uh
disputing you are uh challenging the
election commission okay
today
friday was the last peaceful
day for demonstrations according to the
protesters that have been occupying
areas near the green zone for the third
week well they say it's the last
peaceful day of protest
certainly the pictures that we are
broadcasting right now don't appear to
be
a very peaceful
indeed uh mahmoud abdullah you are in
baghdad for us
the people who are protesting and and
again holding chairs aloft uh certainly
charging towards the security forces
clearly unhappy
with the way the elections had run but
you're based in baghdad you're talking
to other people what's the general sense
in the city
i mean
do
other people feel that the elections
have progressed okay what's the mood
like on the whole
in baghdad following these elections
well the protesters represent only
a mayan or a faction of the iraqi
society and they have been
encouraged they have been supported and
motivated by the political parties
that lost
in the election but the
general uh uh chance in iraq
is that
this election the october election is uh
the uh the the the third the fi the
fifth election that has been conducted
since uh the fall of saddam hussein's
regime in 2003
but they say that it's it has been
monitored by international supervisors
it has been
monitored by the united nations by
europe the european union and even by
representatives
of all uh the political uh uh parties
despite the fact that uh this is
the
the best in in terms of
organization in terms of
logistics the best election to be held
in iraq in uh
18 years but yet the turnout was very
low it was only 41
out
so
many people in the street
many people say that they do not believe
in this electoral process because it is
only reproducing the same old
parties but the same old parties are now
having dispute among themselves
those political parties that lost in the
election they have sent their supporters
in the streets blocking the streets
occupying areas near the green zone a
very important area that has
headquarters of diplomatic missions
including the us embassy and also
government
offices they're trying to put pressure
on the government
put pressure on the elector electoral
commission to change something
in the uh vote results to change
something that it can guarantee
they're asking for changes
mahmoud i'm sorry to cut you off the the
the protesters are clearly angry at the
results
uh
they want the results to change but in
terms of the wider political system that
you've just explained to our audience it
appears to be returning the the same
results the same parties getting in is
there a recognition in iraq more
generally that that more reform needs to
be had with it with the entire system
not just the electoral system because if
the same leaders are being returned and
there is unhappiness
with the system uh with the the leaders
that that keep coming back through these
elections is there a recognition more
broadly that the system is not working
well there is there definitely is
because many people say that the same
old system the same old corrupt regime
it has been reproduced over the past
years through corrupt political parties
corrupt officials corrupt
politicians but yet they say that they
hope that this election can bring about
a change especially that this is the
first time opposition parties uh gain in
legislative election remember this
election
has
brought uh opportunity to
the uh a movement an opposition movement
called uh the 2019 october revolution uh
movement it's called tishrin here in
iraq and
uh it has given chance to
representatives of the
revolution of the opposition movement to
take part in this election and win and
they have also achieved
a relative
victory in this uh uh in this election
compared to other elections in the past
so
the first time opposition parties have a
voice they have a chance to take part in
the
legislative body that will
hopefully according to them will uh
make a change will reform and eliminate
the corruption that they have been
suffering from uh for almost two decades
okay mahmoud abdul wahad i will leave it
there for now
uh but thank you very much indeed for
talking us through those developments in
iraq for viewers just joining us we are
showing live pictures of protests
just outside the green zone very near to
the green zone
these protests following the the results
of the elections in october uh clearly
many unhappy with those results and
unhappy that the the hand recount the
manual recount is returning the same uh
results we're going to keep a close eye
on developments in baghdad and bring you
more on this story later in the newshour